[Applause]
imagine a country with a population of
Manhattan but with huge reserves of oil
and gas the country surrounded by the
wealthiest oil-rich monarchies where am
I talking about well that would be
Bahrain a country so tiny that we almost
can't see it on the map yes yes I know
what you're thinking life must be
wonderful here right money for everybody
a prosperous economy and amazing growth
right well no the opposite is in fact
true
bahrain downgraded to junk as political
crackdown continues unabated yeah you
heard that right
bahrain debt is considered to be a junk
bonds on the international market this
means investors are so hesitant about
their economy that they don't believe
bahrain will be able to give back those
loans the truth is things in bahrain
they're getting really really sour if
you've followed visual politic for a
long time you already know that within
the islamic world there are two big
groups Sunni Muslims and Shia Muslims
and well they really hate each other as
you know Saudi Arabia is something like
the Sunni Muslim Hollywood and the
Islamic Republic of Iran is the same but
for the Shia Muslims this is why they've
been in a state of cold war for decades
but in the context of this cold war
Bahrain is actually in the funniest
position of all basically in this
country the majority of the population
is Shia Muslim but the royal house that
rules the country is Sunni Muslim this
is why their monarchs have turns
political oppression in do something of
an art form alright so so far nothing in
this video has probably surprised here
that much but then again the title of
this video is why Bahrain could become
the world's wealthiest country or
something like that honestly at the time
of recording we haven't actually decided
the title of this video but so why do we
save something like that well because of
this rain discovers largest oil field in
countries since 1932
yes dear viewer they already had
dinosaur juice but now they have even
more basically Bahrain could have more
oil than Russia and with a fraction of
Russia's population so basically this
means that there are less people to
split the money with but the question is
is this enough to be the wealthiest
country on the planet
why even with so much oil our Bahrain's
debt bonds still considered to be junk
what the hell is going on in Bahrain
well today we are going to answer all of
those questions but as always let's take
a look back at the history
a golden cage all right if any of you
out there want to become a dictator one
day
here are some pro tips basically there
are two ways to make people follow you
the first one good ol depression the
problem with that though is that if you
go too crazy with the oppression you're
gonna risk a popular uprising and maybe
ending up with Gaddafi there was a
bayonet involved not a good time don't
watch that video we've told you
thousands of times here on visual
politic being a dictator is a risky job
not many of them go and die of old age
but there is an alternative and it's
healthier and it's more sustainable and
is what we're calling the money for
nothing strategy basically you shower
all of your citizens in gold if they're
wealthy and they don't need to get a job
they don't worry about politics
all right so the al-khalifa family the
ruling family in Bahrain has combined
both of these methods in a very
effective fashion in fact the prime
minister who happens to be the King's
uncle holds the world record for the
longest lasting ruler he has been in
power since 1971 nonetheless how can a
sunni muslim families stay in power for
such a long time in a country with a
Shia majority population
well as we must before we have the good
old Iron Fist protest against the
government's hey great you'll
automatically be considered a terrorist
you'll go to jail and you probably
either be given the death penalty or
exile and we're not talking about an
isolated example here this is something
that happens every single week Bahrain
strips 115 of nationality over terrorism
allegations over 700 people in Bahrain
have had their citizenship revoked since
[Music]
and yes I know what you're going to say
oh come on Simon don't be such a
snowflake in other democratic countries
they'd retire your citizenship too and
of course well you're right but the
difference is the proportions for
example in the United Kingdom there are
some examples sure but in Bahrain we saw
read about hundreds all right so now you
might say well things are changing Simon
I mean the world is evolving the Middle
East it's getting more modern well I'm
sorry to say but in this case that's not
true at all in fact the opposite is true
in 2011 the Shia citizens took to the
streets as part of the Arab Spring
[Music]
Saudi Arabia along with the United Arab
Emirates sent troops to help the
Bahraini government to suppress these
demonstrations so today one out of every
500 people in Bahrain are political
prisoners among them many Shia leaders
but not only that since 2011 Bahrain has
passed new laws to make it easier to
retire one citizenship and believe me
losing Bahraini citizenship is a big
shame losing citizenship means that you
lose all of your rights
you'll have to give up your passport
your driver's license you cannot own a
house a car a phone or a bank account
you cannot marry in the country and if
you decide to leave you cannot go back
if you happen to stay well you can't
leave in summary opposing the government
turns you into a second-class citizen
and well this is a big shame because
being a first class citizen in Bahrain
it's actually pretty great and this this
is where that money for nothing policy
comes into play this is what we call
bahrain's social contract basically if
you forget about politics you don't have
to worry about anything looking for a
job you can get one in the government
and don't worry nobody's gonna check if
you even go to the office
need to pick up some things in the
supermarket don't worry everything is
super cheap because it's all subsidized
need fuel for your car
well that's also crazy cheap all right
so now you might be wondering what well
does if I don't want to work for the
government Simon I don't like it I want
to work in a private business well still
no problem the government guarantees
quotas for local workers so no
immigrants is going to take away your
job this is actually the funniest part
of all the immigrant quotas basically
they're there to reserve the coolest
jobs for the locals
for example 50% of bank workers have to
be from Bahrain in the cool fancy shops
it's 30% but construction workers was
just 5 why well because he wants to lay
bricks under the hot Bahraini Sun this
is why 55% of the Bahraini population
are immigrants and they are the ones who
actually get the country's work done and
well to be fair I need to make an aside
here look having more immigrants than
locals is very common in the Middle East
for example foreign citizens make up 75%
of Qatar's population but Bahrain is a
pioneer in another way they are one of
the few countries that ban the so-called
Kafala and so what is the kuffara all
about well this is a sort of modern-day
slavery the Kafala system links foreign
workers with a national who is their
patron this patron can decide whether
the immigrants can change his or her job
or even leave the country at all so well
Bahrain has actually abolished this
inhuman practice so well that's good
nonetheless despite all of this what you
might now wonder is well can a country
where nobody works actually prosper and
the answer is well of course not
[Music]
[Applause]
$120 living without working is expensive
they only manages in Bahrain because of
one thing while oil makes up more than
60% of their exports and 75% of the
government's income but in order to
cover all of the costs the government
needs the oil barrel price at 120
dollars less than that they don't make
enough profit to make ends meet and
tonight may be wondering well is 120
dollars too much or too little well look
at its historic peak that happens in
July of 2008 when oil with it a hundred
and forty seven dollars but as you know
in 2014 oil prices fell in January 2016
they were down at as little as $26 and
this explains news like this
[Music]
S&P cuts bahrain rating to b-plus
so what did they do with low prices and
lack of income of course they took on
more and more debt and the results that
speaks for itself in just two years
public debt has gone from 7% to 70% and
despite crude oil prices going up again
it seems pretty unlikely this will reach
120 dollars a barrel anytime soon so far
Bahrain has already revoked subsidies on
meat products and while this is only the
beginning
la reine will introduce v80 by end of
2018 says finance minister yeah you had
that right in Bahrain there is no income
tax and so far they didn't even have
indirect taxation but the situation is
desperate and they need to create new
taxes that simply didn't even exist
before but what does this mean for
Bahrain well do you remember how this
particular authoritarian rule works well
the sheer population accepts Sunni
oppression in exchange for money for
nothing so when the economics fail
politics fails too now only a miracle
can save the Al Khalifa family and well
that miracle is this one
[Music]
the oil miracle so far Bahrain produces
200,000 oil barrels a day this is
nothing bad with the tens of millions in
Saudi Arabia but it's insane when we
take into account the country size as I
said before Bahrain has just discovered
a big old oil bet and they could start
pumping dinosaur juice in as little as
five years
according to optimistic analysts this
could double production and end the
deficit problem all right so this all
sounds fantastic and wonderful so what
exactly is the problem well if you watch
visual politic often you've probably
have guests in that's that not every
type of oil costs the same to extract
[Music]
and this new oil bed has all the
ingredients needed to be very very
expensive first of all it's under water
that means that bahrain has to build
platforms on the sea floor second his
shale oil which means it's under a rock
you need fracking technology to break
that rock and that fracking technology
is really expensive
[Music]
in this chart you can see the cost of
production of a barrel of oil in
different countries we don't know how
much fracking would cost in Bahrain but
we can look to see how much it costs for
example in the United States if you pay
attention to the chart you can see that
fracking shale oil is significantly more
expensive than extracting oil in more
conventional methods
if Bahrain wants to make a profit the
barrel should cost over $60 but since
they need a huge profit to cover all of
their expenses they need an even higher
market price so wait a second well what
can save Bahrain from ruin well the
answer is the same as other Middle
Eastern countries and that's
diversification they need to produce
other things that's not just oil and
this explains news like this
mandalay opens ninety million dollar
factory of the future in bahrain but of
course if you really want to attract
business from other industries you need
something other than oil bets you need
rule of law you need clear taxes and you
need a government that doesn't send
people to jail without a trial we've
told you several times on this channel
do buying and generally speaking the
united arab emirates started down this
path years ago now saudi arabia is
probably gonna follow suit although yeah
we're not really sure about that and
look it's only a matter of time before
bahrain starts doing the same but of
course if those economic reforms mean
that the Bahraini people have to pay
taxes or even you know work hard then
the ruling family is gonna be in dire
straits
[Music]
so the big question now becomes do you
think the Bahraini citizens are going to
accept such an authoritarian government
if they no longer enjoy the money for
nothing policy do you think they're
going to find a way to reform their
system well please leave your answer in
the comments section below also please
visit the reconsider media site the
podcast that provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and do you
not forget that we publish brand new
videos every week so subscribe to this
channel hit that Bell icon so you won't
miss a post and if you like this video
do give us a thumbs up as always I'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and here even
more of my love the voice you can join
us at reconsider media we have a podcast
at reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]